c'est un mal chronique qui frappe nos
bornes de collecte des vols notamment
sur les communes de fort de france et du
lamentin les malfrats parviennent à se
glisser à l'intérieur comme le montre
cette vidéo amateur vêtements et
chaussures trier ici par la population
sont souvent revendus leur est parfois
laissé en vrac à même le sol au centre
de tri du lamentin l'on a rapatrié une
dizaine de bornes endommagée par ces
tentatives d'intrusion j'utilise à
poigne et ici comme échelle et se
positionne et ils font basculer et en
basculant comme les sacs de vêtements
ils basculent la nature de la bombe mais
il y en a d'autres qui sont utilisés la
bascule passe entre la bascule ici et le
3 et tombe à l'intérieur il est même
arrivé que au moment de la levée des
bombes que les collecteurs en ouvrant la
bombe ou quelqu'un à l'intérieur
l'intrusion dans les bornes n'est pas
sans risque en mars 2010 est un original
y est même mort étouffé
pour l'association le problème a pris
une telle ampleur que certaines bornes
ont été déplacées nous avons un
préjudice d'image parce que par respect
pour ceux qui nous donnent des vêtements
avec moi je voudrais leur expliquer de
ne pas se décourager dans la démarche
qu'ils ont entamée de solidarité
vis-à-vis de la cise leur expliquer que
nous avons pris la mesure du problème
des vandales du vandalisme et de la
dégradation des bornes et que nous
sommes à pied d'oeuvre pour trouver une
solution
l'ampleur des vols pourraient atteindre
50 tonnes en 2010 8 800 tonnes ont été
collectées pour revente à petit prix
dans les boutiques solidaires mais aussi
revente à l'export vers les filières de
revalorisation dans l'immédiat l'assise
va déplacer certaines bornes vers des
quartiers moins exposé
ça fait déjà de la peine de savoir qu'il
ya des gens malhonnêtes comme ça demain
on a dit ça c'est pour les démunis
donc en gros voilà si les gens pouvaient
éviter de voir ce genre de comportement
là ce serait bien l'île compte 80 bornes
de ce type aujourd'hui l'ambition de
l'assise est de tripler ce chiffre
l'activité permettent aussi l'insertion
de dizaines de martiniquais à tous les
stades du processus